radical republican congresswoman  marjorie taylor greene of gazpacho and  peachtree dish fame is now saying that  trans people are the most dangerous  people in america i think some of the  most dangerous people in america are  trans terrorists not only is this  bone-headedly stupid number two trans  people are a tiny percentage of people  in america so to be dangerous as a group  the math of it doesn't make any sense  and of course number three what about  the really dangerous people the radical  trumpists the white supremacists the uh  would-be mass shooters and all of these  people something tells me they're  actually dangerous but as usual it's  another con job from these trumpist  right-wingers